it's friday again which means top gaming
stories and Hortense if you might hit a
Jew away the next three to four minutes
let's get that stuff destiny has a new
weapon type the trustee sidearm during
their prison of the elders livestream
this week Bungie also announced that
players will now be able to equip these
new classes of guns as secondary weapons
which have elemental damage and a super
high rate of fire probably because
they're all tiny and stuff the new gowns
also feature high stability and free low
stats the president of the elders is a
new co-op arena mode and will be
included with the upcoming house of
wolves expansion next up Warner Brothers
has owned the eye of game is by
announcing a fairly expensive DLC pack
for batman arkham knight you think they
just learned to expect it by now the dlc
comes in the form of a forty dollar
season pass which will let you play as
Batgirl in her own story expansion
players batman in new story missions
play is the whole damn team in an add-on
called gotham city stories and get
things like character skins iconic
Batmobiles thing to racetracks and some
crime fighter challenge maps that might
sound like quite a few features but a
lot of gamers still felt like they
weren't getting our bat for their buck
particularly considering the initial
lack of detail provided by the publisher
concerning what gamers will get for
their money which is more than half the
cost of the actual game one of brothers
have said that they will be releasing
more details later on this makes free
stuff is for those of you who've already
picked up dragon age inquisition the
first piece of free dlc is what Bioware
are calling a quote premier shopping
destination where you can buy all the
weapons crafting materials and items you
need as well as gaining access to the
mirror of transformation which lets you
change your
agonists facial features the other block
of DLC is multiplayer focused and lets
you craft an item called dragons call so
you can face off against dragons to up
the ante this pack also adds a new
pharrell's and castle and three new
agents to fight with including
skywatcher a bar called Zilla the
virtuoso and isabella from Dragon Age to
the my dragon age two protagonists
actually broke up with to pursue Anders
so I guess that'll make things awkward
for hostage guy hold next up world of
warcraft have lost almost 3 million
subscribers in three months but it's
still topping the MMO charts Warcraft
had 7.1 million subscribers on much 31
down from the 10 million they had at the
end of 2014 Activision Blizzard an to
turbo interesting the price increases in
some regions as well as they quote
strong uptake of value-added service
soften the blow of the locked
subscribers despite the drop Wow remains
the top subscription based MMO in the
world
finally there's been a bit of drama
between green man gaming and setup react
red and here's where we're at with it
TMG has been offering digital codes at
The Witcher 3 4 39 bucks although set of
koyuk insists they never made a deal to
give GMD those codes so there could be a
legitimate tmd have since come out to
say that they tried to sort out a deal
with set a project but were unsuccessful
so they have been sourcing keys from
third-party retailers that set of
project did decide to work with that has
allowed some concerns that SATA project
would be getting no money from the sales
of those keys GMG said they suspect that
the publisher opted not to work with
retailers who would be competing with
their newly launched drm free platform
GOG galaxy as for how this affects you
GMG said they were taking a hit to their
profits to get you the game cheaper but
if you want to support set up rigs
directly you can always fork out another
20 bucks to pick up the witcher 3 on
your gold galaxy or wherever else takes
your fancy let me know down in the
summers when you cared about this week
and did you think world of warcraft is
going to be knocked off its pedestal
anytime soon as light or wine
as for what's on site this week check
out my chest episode on the best game
you want ever Lucy goes over the hardest
gaming device in two minutes and catch
the very last cam and sub episode of
Skyrim mod that is it for me this wish
be sure to have yourself and also
weekend and I will catch you again on
Monday